for more than a decade Google Streetview
cameras have been recording the world
around us Street View over the years has
gone to literally every corner of the
planet we've gone to dense urban areas
we've gone to the tops of mountains
we've taken it underwater we've taken it
to islands populated primarily by sheep
we have taken it to the International
Space Station now there's a new camera
rig on the road that will capture our
world in greater detail than ever before
on the top you'll see the rosette in the
past the ball was about this big and now
we've went from 15 cameras down to 7
cameras there are 20 megapixel sensors
behind each one of these lenses expect
sharper more contrast images and fewer
stitching errors like these from santa
cruz california one of the first places
the new cameras have recorded the
toucans in the front in the back our
laser radars and those are used to
position us in the world and then down
here is the is the side looking HD
cameras which are designed for picking
out business names and street signs that
data is then analyzed by Google's
artificial intelligence which is learn
to know what parts of an image warrant
the most attention this is an actual
example of a real Street View image
taken in Brazil of a business a tire
shop I actually think in addition to
actually being able to pull out useful
information like what these words are it
does something a little neat it realizes
the title in this case and I'm going to
screw up the pronunciation because I
don't speak Portuguese but is zilina
news but it manages to actually ignore
the brand names the phone number stuff
like that that's kind of spurious and
what's interesting about that is that's
kind of what a human is doing - one of
the other nice things that the attention
mechanism allows you to do is this model
is able to learn kind of almost in an
end-to-end sense what normalized text
looks like so in this particular
situation it's learned that when it sees
a V on a street sign what we typically
care about is the word Avenida PR es
period typically refers to Presidente at
least in this market this sort of image
recognition up
- mapping can not only make for more
accurate directions but it can also help
keep up with rapid growth and change in
mega cities like Lagos Nigeria the Lagos
work was actually a really neat
application of a number of these
pipelines we've built some of them deep
learning based that allow us to look at
a couple of different inputs including
the Street View imagery and very quickly
populate the map in areas where
otherwise we might have to spend an
awful lot of protracted effort what
Google is doing here is what Google has
always done and done so well it's
indexing people expect that we've
indexed the world's websites and
generally at the world's information
indexing the world spaces is actually a
far more challenging product problem
even if people have the same expectation
of us so by being more able to deliver
on those expectations by putting the
power in people's hands we think that we
can we can have happier users now Google
wants you the public to help by
contributing street views of your own
thanks to an explosion of relatively
inexpensive 360 degree cameras nearly
anyone can contribute their own fresh
images to Google Maps the newer cameras
are now increasingly capable of 360
video capture at higher resolutions and
so with the Street View app what we've
done is really lean into that by
allowing you to collect video 360 video
on the go while you're driving biking
walking whatever it may be and actually
just collect a ton of individual 360
photos from that stringing that back
together into the traditional Street
View experience that you're familiar
with from something like this one caveat
Google won't automatically scrub
user-generated captures to blur out
faces but you can choose to do so in the
app always make sure that you respect
the privacy tensions and requests of
anybody that you're passing by a lot of
people don't want to be in public
imagery so record carefully knowing that
your contributions will help Google in
its quest to index the world and
maintain it Maps dominance
we see our job on the Google Maps team
as building a data set that helps really
capture all the knowledge understanding
of the real world and bring that into
digital form and a lot of what we're
doing whether it's with Street View with
our user-generated content and the
ability for people to contribute their
own knowledge and understanding is
really helping to build a deeper data
set of knowledge about the world so that
when people come to Google and ask
questions about the world around them we
have more and more of the answers
[Music]